well hello hello
and welcome to another episode of
stevo's
wild ride this one's just plain special
we went to mike tyson's training
facility where he's getting ready for
this
killer new return to boxing and man
his whole compound is epic we showed up
and they had this
medical thing and everybody got rapid
coveted
testing and then once you pass
then in you go you know we did we drove
the wild ride
studio right in there got mike tyson
in the van oh dude strap on your seat
belts because this
is a wild ride ladies and gentlemen
mike tyson yeah baby
dude you look fantastic thank you steve
you look good as well
yeah dude what an honor man to have you
in here how do you like this i was
looking at
this is really amazing yeah here's this
piece of art signed by mike tyson i
bought it at a charity auction
i agree that is pretty awesome so is
this every uh
fight poster from omaha fights i believe
yeah dude how about that man yeah that's
that's worth some money right there
so dude you're getting ready to return
to boxing how long have you been
yeah 15 years 15 years yeah i lost 100
pounds
yeah you did yeah getting prepared for
this this is something i really
envisioned with my my league but my um
legends league only and i'm just this is
gonna be me
branching out with me the lead of the
league
fighting the main event and this is
gonna be awesome we're gonna have all
fighters all basketball players
everybody that's
over 50 they think is over the hill but
still beautiful and
and then shaped like myself hey come to
us we're gonna let you play some more
we're gonna get you a team
it will be football basketball baseball
whatever
it is yeah did this this one just told
me that wayne gretzky reached out to you
yeah listen
it's just really insane yeah dude
oh man 50 and over you're going to be uh
competing pretty soon
right hey i want you to officially meet
scott randolph my co-host
right here yeah yeah
so dude you're on fire man you're you're
on fire dude it's so good
hey man everything is um to the universe
man everything to the universe good
listen it wasn't for
i'll pray to be tall it wasn't for the
universe man what would i be doing man i
i didn't run in 15 years now i'm out
running
i'm running i ran out the other day i
ran 2.2 miles in 15 minutes and i did
3.2 miles
and 23 minutes i just i just keep
running and enjoying myself
and um i can't believe this is happening
yeah
dude epic man how long does it take you
to lose 100 pounds because i it's taken
me three years to lose 10 pounds
well it took me around four months four
months yeah
it's all diet and running yeah pretty
much you gotta do the vegan thing
for a couple of months and once the once
you do the vegan thing once you get
two or three months in the vegan thing
boom everything
starts dropping you know i actually
am aware that you can eat strictly vegan
and become totally fattened absolutely
because
by doing that you have to be mo listen
motion relieves tension you just have to
continue to keep emotion
yeah for sure the best desserts are
vegan desserts
oh yeah so [ __ ] good and they have so
many calories though
they're just healthy but you're still
going to get in the way yeah it's all
about keeping the god don't worry it's
vegan you just keep eating dessert
so dude i feel like we have so much to
promote because you have your hands in
so many different businesses like
first let's start with marijuana oh wow
how does the marijuana is really doing
well
and it's not really well it does well
not because we actually
sell the the flower and then we really
use packages we sold the packaging
to it and that was and that's a big um
that's a big profit in itself yeah yeah
because we don't really
touch them because i don't know if it's
um
nationally um pretty much legalized you
know i think i know for recreation
i know for medical use but not used not
nationally yeah
california you can do it just for fun so
you know you can get in trouble if
you're touching it and so we just
package it pretty much right okay we had
uh
billboards in hollywood right at the
same time you had uh
what was with the rolling papers the
partnership with the tyson ranch
polaroid yeah and i had the one with the
duct tape
yeah dude listen look at this
people mean you're the last two people
they think be doing this
right now right 100 live doing this
right now
yeah that nobody would think we would be
alive in the first place man no
that's what i'm always happy to see
that's when they tell me you i mean like
when a weird way part of my conscience
if you're doing good i'm doing good
we're laughing
dude i love it laughing at a lot of
people who didn't make it
we thought we wouldn't make it always
talk crazy about us
did you guys talk about podcasting in
that bathroom at that mansion
and nothing did i know what a podcast
was
right and speaking of podcasting made
you you beat me to it you got your
hot boxing podcast and uh i gotta say
that when i was on that with you
i think that was the most
[ __ ] entertaining podcast i have ever
been a part of i think it's the second
highest
oh is it the second highest after eminem
no
who no third then third one because it
was this other guy
but they meant them i forgot rock he got
a couple of million and a few hours oh
dude i mean
yeah that's a good one man it was like
three million in the first day yeah
holy [ __ ] that's that's just insane so
so podcasting's going great
that's another business you got you got
a with with the marijuana stuff that's
great
all right you had this huge compound it
was gonna be uh
oh it's gonna still be it's gonna be a
um a titan
and that what was it palm springs area
yeah yeah in palms desert right here and
it's not too far
from coachella i believe and then we
have a thousand acres and we're
we're getting it um pretty much um
position where we can
roll it down and start building right
[ __ ] a man so you've got that then
you've got the legends league
yes and that's what and that's my baby
now because um
once i started to make this statement
with me and roy jones
you know middle-aged fighters and all
the other middle-aged athletes started
calling me jerry rice and everybody
jerry rice has so much enthusiasm and
him playing on the field with we'll get
i'm talking about like super bowl
ratings
yeah i mean it's him playing his fan
base is bigger than
the gentleman that's playing his
position on the 49ers now
right that makes sense to me [ __ ] dude
he's not playing my buddy tony hawk
i'm doing a stunt with him this weekend
why are you doing this
not safe it's cool yeah
dude tony hawk uh he's wait i think he's
53 now
that's the same age as you we could put
him on the show too
yeah i met him before he's the cool guy
dude it's incredible with tony hawk did
i say it all the time though
very humble he's the best yeah rogan's
53 so he can
he can do the announcement yes i'm
considering him as well that's cool
that'd be great to get rogan to uh to
announce the fight with roy jones that's
awesome
yeah mean dude he's awesome he's always
mad and he's awesome
that's cool he's unbelievable okay so i
got a question i think uh
i i i saw headlines okay i saw
don king talking in all the media
saying oh i'm all good with mike tyson
man we've worked it all out and you know
what i thought when i heard that
i thought man that's great news i love
to hear it but i'll believe it when i
hear it from mike
absolutely i have i can't afford to be
angry anybody give that energy away man
we're not going to be here that long you
know i want to give energy to something
powerful that's going to come back
and return so she did communicate with
don king and and uh
just everything yeah everything's
beautiful i love it okay great beautiful
because that's what i realized um once
you start
experiencing love you have to experience
forgiveness self-forgiveness and you go
through hope
you know i mean lineage and forgiveness
in different parts of life and then you
realize that um
at the end of the day we're dead it's
over right
that's true man yeah it's that's true
now you're talking to
to joe rogan on his podcast about how
like uh that fighting um
they did that you could it was like an
animal party that you couldn't
like let lose the the
and then you just said [ __ ] it i'm gonna
let it loose i don't know
i guess um i never knew how much good i
could do doing how many people i could
help doing it yeah it's just um
for me to fight and buy another house or
a plane or
whatever a dog or a cat whatever
to buy anything right it just doesn't do
it anymore
all right you know that doesn't do it
for me anymore but if i can help
what i spend on myself if i can help
i don't know 10 000 people that would be
awesome wouldn't that sound more awesome
helping 10 000 people
than one is that the big screen tv or
feeding a village of ten thousand people
yeah yeah isn't that a trip yeah when'd
you come up with that realization
i have a son um and um
he goes to haiti and build dams and lay
and i'm afraid to go to haiti and this
guy's only 18 he's been there five times
slept over this stage over there
know the people and i said hey i have to
go too
how could this guy have more balls than
me he's only 17 years old
yeah huh balls are uh i think you do
just fine
did you watch the tiger king yeah it was
brilliant yeah
you were like the original tiger guy oh
man
you're the original tiger king yeah but
joe exotic is pretty awesome
holy [ __ ] what the
he got the two boyfriends he got the
horse the guns he's hate the other lady
he really actually wants to kill this
lady and he makes music videos on like
how he wants to kill her
but he's not the musician he's just
lip-synching the music
yeah what's crazy is like the whole
world shut down in march
and the whole world had eyes on tiger
king i mean what a perfect storm for
that
yeah tell me about it that's how you got
in trouble to me people were watching
yeah everybody's in jail now um
how did you get your tiger how'd that go
down i'm in prison right
can i just say how much i love mike
tyson
what a bro and speaking of bros
it's probably mostly dudes clicking on
the mike tyson podcast right so i'm
talking to you gentlemen
and when you're getting busy with a
chick
what i want to know is what's she
finding down there
are you out of control does it stink
is it hairy and disgusting well
if it is it's time for that to stop
and that's why i'm so happy to have my
relationship with
manscaped right manscaped just plain
rules
the other day my girl she caught me with
the nose here she said whoa whoa you got
a nose here
yeah you know what with my manscaped
weed whacker
boom it's gone didn't even have to look
in the mirror i knew it was gone
right now when i'm shaving my balls
i got my lawnmower 3.0 right here
this thing will never
cause me any grief just shaves
everything up
no problem it's the best ball trimmer in
the world
yeah and bald deodorant foot deodorant
ball tone come on get your [ __ ] together
guys all right so now how are you gonna
do this you're gonna go to manscape.com
stevo and what are you gonna get 20 off
your order
yeah plus free shipping so again
for free shipping 20 off your order go
to manscape.com
stevo now let's hear about tigers
so i'm talking to my friend tony and
he's a car dealer right so
i'm talking to him and he's getting he
said listen such and such owed me some
money if he don't pay me my money i'm
gonna sell some of these cars and get
some animals some pets
i said yeah what kind of pesticide you
know like a cougar a jaguar
or some horses i said really he said
yeah mike what do you think see you and
your flyers at 50 for right i think you
look in the white tiger and you're
driving
you know passenger seat and i'm in
prison i'm saying wow that would be
awesome coming back like that
i said yeah so when i got home i had two
tiger cubs waiting oh [ __ ]
wow and then how i did i mean i remember
pictures of you with the tiger that
looked like
full grown yeah like until they were 14
ahead of them
so you had you had you kept the tiger
for 14 years
yeah damn not that much yeah
and uh and then what happened to well
she had to go she started getting old
and sick and we had kids and stuff
so she they took her to like uh i wanted
to say not a
zoo but uh habitat sanctuary yeah yeah
so dude i had no idea you kept that
tiger for 14 years is just one tiger or
two
i had two of them damn is there ever a
moment where you're like oh [ __ ] like
these tigers
can turn on me only when they're
together
i worry about it because listen you got
one guy over here at 400 pounds yeah one
guy over here
and they start playing even playing how
am i going to get involved
and then they imagine when they're mad
at each other what am i going to do
joe exotic would get in there no you
can't do this stuff so
that's for television yeah so how do you
take care of
of tigers do you have someone like uh
well i had a trainer i had two few
trainers
and i also had um i had this awesome
and and cavemen they had a whole house
and and that was in vegas yeah i get i
had a whole house i
my house was like what twelve thousand
feet square foot and the house next to
mine's probably nine
thousand square foot and i used that
house for the habitat for the
cat that's amazing yeah did the tigers
ever eat any of the pigeons
no no they but they do like horse meat
and i live right next door to wayne noon
and they
always look up and have the eyes on the
horse
uh-huh so
you know the tigers and pigeons is just
a big thing oh yeah opinions is my life
and i have
um i have a i don't know i had a lot but
i had
like 100 probably in vegas and i got
around
40 here in the california a hundred
pigeons in vegas and 40 in california so
i would do that yeah what is it about
raising pigeons i mean you let them go
and they have different like the rollers
and i have the rollers
that i participate in but also in the
east coast i have
the homeless and the homeless with
championships and they become
thoroughbreds is it racing pigeons
yes they've been raising pigeons before
christ
hmm wow that's incredible yeah
they've been domesticated since the
beginning of time pigeons are just
survivors yeah i've never heard of
racing pigeons i remember them like
sending messages
you look at your phone and find out what
is the the highest price for racing for
the opinions you would be
um mind boggling oh yeah yeah it would
bother your mind
what's what's the course probably what
do you want from
from paris to england to england to
paris to france where how far you went
to but put one be a 20 mile bird a
hundred mile bird
a thousand mile birth what you want to
bet how much you want to bet you want a
better dynasty on it
and it's like whoever gets there and
back first for the blue bloods
jesus and those guys
[ __ ] some people got birds listen some
people have the bloodline since the
crusades
yeah like they have 500 there's some of
the arabs
they have 500 year bloodline
with the birds especially in the middle
east and in europe
these guys bloodlines blow your mind
yeah you're just pitting you look at it
as a flying rat this guy's bloodline is
royalty
you know it's crazy right charlemagne
it's really nuts
that's fine yeah that's that i never
even knew that
i [ __ ] love my tyson i did hey you
know
when when you came out to see our show
man we got we got our tour dude that
meant the world to me man and we have
always supported we had mike tyson in
the audience on the bucket list tour
dude it was just so cool man
[ __ ] hit the family just talking to my
wife the [ __ ] hitting the family
isn't how um yes the energy works i was
just talking to my wife
yesterday about um that show when this
show would show the fan and [ __ ]
cause the thing about [ __ ] when it's
like doesn't go into water it just
smells and it smells really bad
all right people sick sometimes yeah
yeah all right and his chick just
handled that my girl's down dude my girl
is down as [ __ ]
you see that some of those um indigenous
people they wipe up and [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] probably getting
that's probably the healthiest way to be
man you want to keep your immune system
on its toes dude you want to
you want to if you live in an incubator
then you're just vulnerable
that's awesome that's why all this hand
sanitizer is the best um
fertilizer yeah because there's a
particular um bug in it it's a flying it
lives like for three hours
of the day and at the end of the day
when they dropped when they when they
dropped the eggs they do it in manure or
some [ __ ] it's
a water flake full of shitty and that's
how they that's that's
[ __ ] but we heard that like my aunt was
really sick and they gave her fecal
transplant
have you heard of that no were they
where they take like healthy young like
teenage
like [ __ ] and they they transplant it
through your immune system
virgin [ __ ] i don't it's like it's like
younger [ __ ] and then
it has like benefits to keeping you
young and healthy
sometimes i think i'm a piece of [ __ ]
you know
you're talking about the wrong guy and
your guy rob your partner yeah yeah
he gave me this this uh cbd spray
right like i i'm nervous about with the
like
weed or cbd anything that i would like
drink or
eat like i don't want to [ __ ] with it
but i got the the cbd spray
to spray on uh on my muscles and stuff
that [ __ ] helped me dude
listen um we don't sell dreams man we
sell reality
yeah dude so i i want to [ __ ] shout
it out the
the robbie hickman yeah i want to shout
out that mike's
cbd spray [ __ ] kicks ass dude
yeah i i spray it on before i go to bed
and everything man
the aim's the please yeah dude
what's it what's it called in the name
of it
copper gel that's it copper gel that's
the cbd spray
yeah dude the [ __ ] the for the the
living legends man the 50 year old
guy has been beating up their body dude
that cbd spray helps you wake up in the
morning man it helps you get out of bed
feeling all right so how now
i wanted i'm picturing like back in the
80s when you were going around with like
an
entourage of a hundred people or
whatever it was the crazy [ __ ] it was
just people dad are you still in touch
with any of those people today
you know speaking of relationships with
old friends
can i tell you the relationship that
i've rekindled lately
with my skateboard yeah dude i've been
shredding
actually i've been burning an insane
amount of calories
in the last couple days alone look at
this skateboarding right here
3 500 calories i burned
yeah the day before that i had a huge
day as well
um you know what i was playing ping pong
so aggressively that that day i burned
3 200 calories how do i know all of this
because i wear
a whoop strap okay it is the
top fitness tracking device ever works
as a membership
service so you sign up you get a free
tracking device okay wear it on your
wrist
never have to take it off because you
slide the charger
right on there man i i never want to
take this thing off
plus it knows exactly how much i'm
sleeping
how much my body recovers even gives me
tips on what i need to do to be
healthier
and i'll tell you i feel really good
because i've been kicking ass
and i want the same for you so
how are you going to do this you're
going to go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p
dot-com you're gonna use the promo code
stevo
and that will give you 15 off
at checkout again it's 15 off at
checkout
using the promo code stevo at woop.com
and you're gonna have more insight into
what's going on with your body
than you possibly could any other way so
give it a shot
okay it's time to get fit now let's hear
about this whole
entourage uh yo only a few most of them
dead
it's a few here's a few yeah
and i love when i hear you talking about
uh you know every everything that
happened in your life and you have
sincere gratitude like hey man if i
didn't go the way that i went then i
wouldn't be where i'm really i wouldn't
be here with you now
yeah something more drastic could have
happened and and uh dude
and i'm really interested in your uh the
undisputed truth thing
that you did with with spike yes that
was um
a really high point in my life something
i really
my wife invented it and so um
it was just a hit it was just a
no-brainer spike lee got involved and
he has highlighted it on broadway
and now we go all over the world with it
yeah that's epic and i kind of borrowed
the idea of like doing the storytelling
but you're showing photos and videos and
all the multimedia
entertainment yeah following the story
once they see that
was that was a residency in vegas for a
while right yes do you prefer the
residency in vegas versus touring all
over
both like i love vegas but i like to go
all over because i can't believe how
many people come out i'm saying [ __ ]
yeah yeah when we're in um what's what
part of odessa texas
all these red naked hillbillies are
packed for sure
you know i mean five nine thousand packs
yeah
and now they're it's a sequel to it
right so yeah it's a follow-up show
yes and what's that what's the
difference between the sequence
it took most of the we took out most of
the longer parts and putting its
explosive parts and it's just really uh
it's
constant hits yeah [ __ ] amen
so what do you think about uh the
the jake paul guys on the um i think
that's very
interesting i'm looking forward to see
that before my fight it's
it's it's really i don't know um listen
jake paul dwight do right yeah he looks
really good in the midst i don't know
how he's gonna do the ripper and the
messy look like he could fight
i mean he fought ksi right uh it was
logan paul
ksi and jake paul was on the undercard
on that one but jake paul's fought
a couple times i mean the thing about
these youtubers fighting
whether you want to like hate on it
whether they're they're good whether
they're bad
the [ __ ] thing is that they've got
people
paying to watch it they've got no but
more than that they got
balls have balls and to never really do
it and do it in front of a bunch of
people and everybody's watching forget
his crowds and they're not
that takes balls yeah i i mean
i'm pretty impressed even just with the
with their fighting
that freaks me out because that's
something we do for a living and
you know this was something people avoid
their whole life
and they're going there wasn't doing
anything you know the dishes crazy yeah
i think it was really exciting it's
really exciting i think it was a good
business decision to get
jake paul on like on the card man i like
that guy
yeah yeah they have a fight coming up
soon that's the same card is here same
card
november 12th november 28th it's
november 28th
okay november [ __ ] 28th dude
and uh and it's pay-per-view but you but
you own the league
yes i'm in the league of a league of my
own so now you're mike tyson and
don king well i'm definitely mike tyson
but but you're the promoter yeah yeah
[ __ ] a man
i heard an interesting story uh with
henry cejudo talking about you and doing
the frog
down oh yeah the toad is is the toad the
same thing as dmt or is it
it's completely different it's totally
different um
it just takes you to another dimension
of life that we never experienced before
you know you realize that this is once
you do some um
i don't know whatever you thought
alternative medicine like the toad the
scorpion the lizard tail
the white cobra do that stuff and
it trust me you change your perspective
on you yeah
in life you'll never be the same again
man yeah it's crazy but it's all i mean
is all that stuff vastly different like
dmt trip versus uh the toad trip
was kind of the same it's the same but
it's the toad is another
animal the toad is where you um
i won't say you see it but you feel it
so much that you do it appears to you
yeah you know your ancestors
your ego death you experience ego death
and that's very scary
yeah you know like that man hey imagine
this imagine everybody
in the world knowing your deepest
secrets you wouldn't want them to know
if they knew they would look at you
different
and then you have the feeling that
everyone knows everything about you
and it's scary then that's just scary
man it's just so
trip it's just you see your ancestors
you may see some
great grandparents you might see some
answers you never even met before and
it's just nuts man how long does that
trip last for
listen only 20 minutes but you're gonna
get like a hundred thousand years of
experience
that sounds about right time doesn't
exist dude
nothing oh that's crazy
being that dimension where nothing
exists and
yeah everything that you love doesn't
even exist you forgot that
and that means and that tells me that um
when we do die
that um we can't go to the to the great
universe and say hey
it was those guys fought that did that
it would be you and him
all everything that you ever loved you
would forget about it you wouldn't even
know you have a wife a kid or a mother
that
you have to take care of you forget
about them and then you come out
the first thing you say hey where's my
family at with your school
you know you you know you did something
that never been done to you before
you're having hallucinations like that
when you were tripping
ah i had a lot of hallucinations man but
it didn't
no listen i was on cocaine when i first
did it
that coke that's the one when that hit
me man that cocaine
didn't even exist cocaine it was uh well
that stopped me from doing drug drugs
because after doing that all that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] weak to me
yeah this is in my mind this is a real
drug
this is a real drug it doesn't it kills
you you get all those other drugs that
inflate your ego is deadly liquor
cocaine
all that stuff that um that's just
deadly
no good for your health this is also
something that
kills the ego but enhance the body in
the brain
it probably keeps you out of jail oh
listen
you know let's imagine the whole world
did this yeah nobody will ever have a
fight with nobody everybody
you see through the you see the beauty
in life you see
it's just inconceivable i can't even
articulate it
yeah it's so beautiful yeah henry cejudo
did a pretty cool talk on that and i was
really impressed with henry cejudo
yeah and henry cejudo's
super smart guy yeah yeah yeah
he he is man and he you love mma
yeah me too dude i [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] the people are awesome
yeah you know what i've been i've
watched every fight man you're like the
contender series i [ __ ] love the
contender series did you see him
henry when he fought that guy who was
that guy and he was he got the big cut
and he had to come back and he knocked
the guy out
the last fight he did cruise with the
guys
yeah yeah of course i watch every single
fight under undercard when the
fight pass prelims start man i'm
watching yeah i mean they're they're
thinking about doing massive doll versus
yeah that'd be pretty good dude epic
scott wanted to ask
if uh you know when you were just
starting to fight
yes so i thought like you know if you
were 16 again or 15 again and
ufc or mma was on the table as well as
boxing would would you
just be a die-hard boxer be a boxer
i would get paid more money yeah
regardless mma is like ufc the biggest
thing in the world
make all the money and everything but
boxers always have 10 times more money
than
um yeah ufc fighters why is that hey i
have no idea
the other one's drawing the money yeah i
don't know yeah
how did that there was some some banter
between you and jon jones about maybe
you said
you said if you want to get paid john
jones you're gonna have to fight me oh
he's just saying in order for them
because
the pay you know the paid difference
between a boxer and mma guy
he'd have to do what um conor did fight
floyd and he had
me to make that big money like 100
million something like that right
so you suggest the month the money is
that's where the money is
mma fighting against boxing guys you
know
first um they could do boxing and some
guys could just try mna
somebody had to try mna i know some
boxers didn't think
but what surprised me i didn't expect um
mcgregor to do that well yeah mm-hmm you
know i expect the floyd to wipe him off
just
humiliate him embarrass him i didn't
expect him to do that well
that impressed me that he last 10 rounds
with the greatest fighter in the last 30
years
40 years you know right that was
impressive
he took his beating like a man didn't
complain that was just
that was just impressive do you uh do
you talk to floyd mayweather
not much periodically if i see him if i
have something to say to him
how about how about 50 cent i took the
50 cent pretty often
when i see him yeah 50 is a boxer
yeah why do you think him a floyd should
bop
what i mean dude they go back and forth
their buddies then they're not buddies
and their buddies and
right oh no they're buddies yeah there's
a movie coming out with jamie foxx
playing you right
well i believe yeah he that's what
that's what i was hurt
okay you don't know much about that i
didn't know a lot about it but oh god
there mike tyson is on fire man
he's killing right now yeah dude so
we're gonna do your podcast too
i would love that i [ __ ] love it dude
i think uh
damn so i'm so honored to be a bro mike
dude and
to have you do this with me man this
message together man
yeah we partied hard and i wanted to say
again
that the most the most [ __ ]
explosively entertaining podcast i have
ever been a part of was the one i
recorded
with mike tyson the hot boxing podcast
i'm going to go ahead and put the link
to that [ __ ] thing
in the description of this one because
it's
so dope man i might have the third
highest
i want to be the [ __ ] i want to be
the second highest
dude it was so good man and uh
yeah and and also that i wanted to say
thank you that
for the the comedy special that i got
duct taped to the billboard for
i asked you before i put that out i said
hey mike mayor are you cool with me
putting out this comedy special where
i'm talking about how we were locked up
in the psychiatric world together we're
doing all kinds of cocaine together you
said
absolutely you said you tell all that
stories you do
do all that and man the story about
us doing all the coke that's in the
psychiatric word
me breaking my nose
on your face with such an honor and the
way that that went down
and all the footage is in the special
dude and and
i just want everybody to see that
because it's so [ __ ] good you guys
have some history
in the psych man and mike says he says
man i was happy to see you i've never
seen anybody i knew in there
because he's like i was in there all the
time
oh my god and uh and oh
like what was probably going through
your guys's head before you guys even
knew you were there and then you run
into each other and you're like what the
[ __ ]
nothing bad
i was trying i was trying to talk my dad
let me run into his fistup like just
hold your fist there and i'll run into
it with my face and try to get a black
eye
and that whole story is epic now you
know what i've been up to
what i've been trying to do i've been
trying to get cauliflower here on
purpose
oh [ __ ] i had to i had chocoladel
ronda rousey jorge mazvidal jon jones
all try to give me cauliflower ear and
it won't work some people i guess they
don't get it you got cauliflower here
yeah kind of how did you get it just
from being punched in the air
no um no yeah i fell off my pigeon coop
was like two
like 20 feet in the air and i fell over
him and this
might hit me in a fight and it got
punked and then i
i got drained and i went to hyperbaric
chamber for a week
and healed it so when you go to
hyperbaric chamber
do you go there like two hours a day or
you stay in there yes
i wouldn't have the heavy claustrophobic
for me oh it's beautiful yes
i feel like you reborn that now that
you're now that you're fighting again
you got you kind of got that
that you you down to try and give me
cauliflower here you are
no way he's biting he's just like leave
me alone
dude dude i would be so i'd be so
excited to have
my truck out of my hair i saw him on
some dead island with some
indigenous people who really never saw
humans before the guy was trying to [ __ ]
you he was trying to bite you
he was trying to do everything after
they stayed this guy can't be a real
neanderthal like that he was the real
thing
ah the cannibals in india yeah man
they're called the
agory tribe they're mostly just
detention horrors
but uh but yeah they're pretty wild they
killed some people
they
they took them in the woods too they
must have ate there yeah they could they
kill people
and they eat them and you guys were just
with them we're just kicking that way
[ __ ] steve charlie they're trying to do
all kinds of weird [ __ ] yeah we were
drinking out drinking whiskey out of
skulls together and [ __ ]
it was funny because they were scared i
can't remember i want to say it was
their whiskey how'd it taste
it taste it's i don't know it tastes
like whiskey i guess
i don't know that there's any different
than uh anything since the beginning of
time people had to get high huh yeah
yeah man
i thought i did this research on the
history of drugs and man that's a trip
i wonder what the first drug was um
lotus flower probably
oh really yeah dude
i'm the biggest starts with the lotus
flower what does the lotus do get you
high
yeah that's all you need to know i
believe
all right do we have anything else we
want we want to
mention with the the cbd products
everything's good man everything's
good the tyson ranch the it's called the
legends league
yes legendary gone and they're the
thousand acres that's the tyson ranch
yes big time palm springs ever palm
springs deadly spring
we got jamie foxx playing a cinema maybe
he is it's most likely he is yeah
and uh you got mike tyson's punch out
part two coming out soon god willing
that's come on i have fun with that
oh really now
did you ever play yourself back in the
day yeah i [ __ ] back then but now i
got skills
i got the skill to pay the bills [ __ ]
dude dude that's amazing video teacher
we did tony hawks putting out his
tony hawk pro skater video a game again
yeah baby now but it's a re-release of
one and two
the video games is a different kind of
money video game i was like real people
now huh yeah
they got teams too virtual reality or
some [ __ ]
you know i like to be involved with that
you know i'm telling you
the floyd mayweather yeah he's he's a
big deal but dude
i i don't mike tyson's the most famous
boxer on the planet period
forever thank you yeah
the most famous boxer on the planet
period forever
dude mike tyson punch out bringing it
back yeah [ __ ] you heard it here first
yeah you didn't did it michael show mike
was part of the uh
the first ufc video game yes i was
yeah that was pretty cool yeah what did
man
all right well i think we've we've
plugged it all
the fight is on november 28th 28th baby
come see me down
come see me die in the floor with blood
and and right now you weigh 210 to the
[ __ ]
fist rip baby look baby baby
watch out yeah yeah dude let's lose
laundry man let's see how beautiful you
look look at me
[ __ ] dude yeah i already want to lose
100 pounds
yeah yeah you get on it man get on that
tyson diet
all right dude let's record yours man
thank you so much for this [ __ ] love
you mike
you're the man dude thank you yeah for
sure yeah
dude what can i say man that kicked ass
and as always i want to thank you for
sticking around to the end of the
episode
i'm guessing we probably have some new
viewers who don't regularly watch
because
for god's sakes this was mike tyson and
if you're a new viewer
here's what we do okay we we screenshot
the uh the podcast anywhere on it you
post that screenshot
tag mike tyson let him know how much you
enjoyed it
and i call that the street team you know
it's kind of promoting the podcast
helping us build because i really enjoy
it i love it and i want it to just
get better and better and i so
appreciate all of you
people who helped to do that to make it
bigger and better and radder
and i just appreciate you all so much so
thank you
and thanks again to mike tyson now
that's the champ